- Welcome, teachers, for
this short guided meditation.
Remind yourself that meditation,
there's no right way to do it.
It's just an opportunity
to still your mind,
take a break from all the
thoughts that you normally have,
the planning, the to-do's of the future,
thoughts of the past,
and just be in the moment, and be still.
So let's start by taking a few deep
and controlled breaths
together in through our nose.
Hold.
And out through our mouths.
In through our nose.
Hold.
And then out through your mouth.
Now I encourage you to continue to breathe
in a deep and controlled way,
but as you do so, try to
put a smile on your face.
It might feel a little artificial,
but I promise it'll actually feel good.
Even if your mood might not
have made you want to smile,
just put a big cheesy smile on your face
as you continue to breathe in.
And out.
So as you go through the rest of your day,
encourage you to take breaks like this,
moment of pause, moment of stillness,
approached with a sense of acceptance,
a sense of curiosity,
even a sense of humor.
And remind yourself that as a teacher,
you give so much of yourself to others,
but you need to have a source of energy.
And so for their sake,
it's important that you
take care of yourself.
It's important that you
give your mind a break,
and be in the moment,
in a moment of stillness and acceptance.
And maybe in a little way,
resolve and refresh
everything that's going on
to tackle the day, the
weeks, the months ahead.
Thank you.